Hello, my name
is Colin Rundel.
And today, I'm going to
tell you a little bit
about a package
I've been working
on recently called parsermd.
This package implements a parser
for R Markdown documents using
the boost spirit
library and C++,
and exposes a series of
functions and data structures
that allow for the manipulation
and evaluation of R Markdown
documents from within R.
So to give you a
little bit of context,
I teach large statistical
computing courses.
And I deliver
assignments to students
in the form of R
Markdown documents.
These R Markdown documents
have very typical structures,
so they have things like YAML at
the beginning, section headings
to keep bits and pieces
organized, instructions
in the form of Markdown
text, and then various code
chunks that include
either example code
or areas where we
want students to enter
their own code to
implement a solution
or something like that.
And this works
really, really well
except one of the
difficulties we have
is that the documents
contain lots of boilerplate
in the form of these
instructions or demo code
that we don't actually care
about when it comes time
to mark it.
And actually, it
distracts from the content
that we are really
concerned with.
And so part of the
motivating reason
for developing the
parsermd package
was a desire to be able to
take these kind of documents
once the students
have turned them in,
and then strip out all
of that boilerplate
to get down to just the stuff
that we actually care about.
And so today, I'll show
you some examples of what
that looks like in practice.
So at its core is this
parse_rmd function,
which reads an R
Markdown document.
And then turns it into a
simple abstract syntax tree.
And so for our
purposes right now,
we don't really need to
understand what that is.
But the key thing to see is all
of those elements we just saw
in that homework
01.rmd are here.
So we see that there's
the YAML is represented.
We have the various
section headings.
We have the markdown
text and the code chunks.
And this is presented
in a hierarchical way,
but it's really just flat.
We're just inferring
the hierarchy
based on the various
heading levels
that we see within the document.
If this hierarchical view
doesn't work for you,
we can also turn this into
a tidy rectangle of data
using the as_tibble function.
And so what we now have
is the same representation
of that data where the AST has
been wrapped up into a tibble,
and we can manipulate
things by looking
at the various other
columns that are there.
But that AST we were just
seeing is still here.
It's now just in its flat form
represented in that ast column
on the right hand side.
So AST, what is that?
How do I work with that?
What do I care about it?
It's a custom data
structure, but it's really
just a list of lists.
And it's all managed by
S3, and it's not something
that you actually need to
worry about in practice.
Because the package implements
a bunch of helper functions.
So if we want a subset
for various elements
on the example I have,
I care about the exercises
and the solutions.
So here, I can use
the subset function
to pull out anything
that matches
exercises with a wildcard
and then solution.
So this gets me all
of the nodes that
belong to an exercise
one, two, or three,
and then the various
answers the students
may have put into
those particular bits
of the document.
I can pull those out.
Once I've done that,
I can then also
manipulate the document further,
so a common issue students
have as they may write
code that has an error.
And if we were to try
to knit that document,
we would not be able to,
because of the error.
So what we can do is we can
then manipulate the code
chunks to add new options.
So this is going to go through,
and set error equal to true
for all of the code chunks.
So that when we
knit the document,
it'll keep knitting
even if there
is an error at any
point in the document.
Once we've done
that, we can then
say turn the document
back in text,
or we can even just
render it directly.
So in this case, I can turn
it back into an HTML document
and examine it.
And so again, this
makes it very easy
to then take the student's code,
pull out the pieces I want,
and then render just
the solution, so
that I can then mark it much
more easily without all
of that other sort
of cruft around.
This works really well.
In practice, it's a
little bit more difficult,
because we depend on the
structure of the document
matching exactly what we expect
when we're extracting things.
And so one of the
things that I've also
done in practice
with this that's
been able to be built
on top of these tools
is the idea of a template,
an automatic feedback
to the students.
So an RMD template is just
a simple representation
of the nodes that
we expect to find
and the various sort of
labels and location references
that we care about
indicate where they are.
And it's just a
simple tibble that we
can generate using the
rmd_template function
once we subsetting for
the elements we want.
And once we have
that, we can then
feed it into another helper
function called rmd_check_template,
which we can then use
that to compare
against the student's work.
So here, I'm comparing
against hw01-student,
and we get a user-friendly
error message
out telling you
exactly what's missing
and what's problematic
about the document.
So in this case, the
student is missing something
in exercise one
and exercise two,
and they're told explicitly
what that is, either
a code chunk or markdown text
or what it's particularly
looking for in that context.
And so this is
something we're actually
able to deploy to students this
semester via GitHub Actions.
And if it's something
that you're interested in,
all of the example code
including the GitHub Action
workflows are
included in the repo
that I've linked at
the bottom there.
Thank you very
much for watching.
Additional details
about the package
are available on
GitHub, and please
let us know if you have any
feedback, if the package breaks
or you have an
interesting use case.
Thanks!